we could tell just by even the first
quarter of a a a football that this was
something that was gonna work out and
here we are entering week number three
of the first inaugural season of the
Alliance of American football which just
received a done din of cash two hundred
fifty million bucks was just committed
to the Alliance of American football by
Tom donned in the owner of the Carolina
Hurricanes and the founder Charlie ever
saw back here in the program good to see
you sir thank you very much
Congrats on the the launch of this thing
thank you and um you know obviously lots
how many months of work went this well
we were we we started this three years
ago but so three years ago we were three
employees thirteen months ago and we're
now a little under 1200 and so what was
it just you sitting around a table
breakfast table lunch table saying when
I you know what no no when I directed
the third when I directed the 34:30
about the XFL the my now had a better
dad was a part I dad and Vince and I was
doing the interviews and I was spending
a lot of time with Tom vite who is now
might had a business but he was the GM
of the XFL and he'd helped launch the
USL the United Soccer League and we just
started trying to say like why didn't
this work and the general consensus was
quality football but also the business
model and so we think we built a
business model that works and clearly
Bill Polian delivered players to
ordinary players and coaches thank the
coaches I mean look what you would what
a league needs to do coming out is it
obviously needs to look like the real
thing which it did not only in some of
the style of play but in terms of you
got CBS the NFL Network bleacher report
all on TNT old friends yes indeed our
old friends who's one long mistake one
lone mistake still still the
highest-rated unscripted show they ever
had it's a great escape yep
fantastic so I got that come on for me
nice reboot reboot bring it back if just
for the Wardrobe I mean one of the great
wardrobes of all let's be honest he's
walking around looking like he stepped
out of GQ Safari edition it's amazing
the bomber jacket yeah James Bond meets
Indiana Jones look at this right there
maybe not just swapped
not so much that outfit but that outfit
we're starting to get there and then
when we got you in the you're in the
Henley with there we go look at me with
the plains behind me
although the beard would have been
better teeth yeah who'd have more rugged
well more mysterious season to my
publish this is like why are you talking
about a show that was on television
years ago it's okay we'll get to the a
this is you know the Rich Eisen show
Charlie that's right alright so let you
know not only do you need as I said it
has to look like it and some familiar
names would be helpful too but viral
moments the first weekend
you got the Berko hit that hit ya was
just something on everybody's phones and
the thing that I was saying is that if
this was the NFL we'd be talking about
fine suspension what was going on in the
blue tent or not instead it was people
just like okay that's a football hit so
a lot of the seriousness that always
surrounds by NFL games was removed and
it just was people reacting for the love
of watching football do you get that
sense though completely having a game of
football that is real which has never
happened before an alternative football
right you've never had everyone's
gimmicky everyone's marketing everyone's
doing everything else having real
football all with all NFL names all NFL
head coaches all NFL GM's all NFL
officials half of our officials are in
the official development program for the
NFL
everything was meant to be real and then
you have that first game and it's an
extraordinary game with great great
plays viral plays we were we were very
happy my dad famously said at halftime
of the first XFL game this is over we're
dead he said yeah well one team had 12
yards of total offense in the first half
so it said that's when he knew that was
that oopsy-daisy right
so is there though like a fine system in
the AF yeah but I mean you have to upon
upon review and I spanked I'm related to
it was a completely legal hit I'd like
our players to remember to clip their
helmets on that would obviously been
helpful
but ultimately there's a forum tackle I
mean we look at that and and that was
good I think from our perspective seeing
actual NFL defenses and actual NFL
offenses Gary Gilbert running the air
raid offense last week right I mean
three throws over 50 yards with with
stunts plays and it was good and then
another viral video was Spurrier well
you're looking at the manna from floods
right at me
god grant me Steve Spurrier Spurrier
radioing his play in telling the
quarterback to tell the receiver to
catch it this time what is it just
fantasy zijn we filmed all the preseason
games during the Pro Bowl weekend and
and Steve at the end of the game you
know they're running their you know
third string guys to see you they're
gonna cut et cetera and they're playing
against San Antonio in San Antonio
starts getting back into it and they are
San Diego rather they start getting back
into it they're getting close and
Spurrier is might turn to his coach and
goes we want to win this game right yeah
two starters back in there the
quarterback you want to score touchdown
because Diego's just just sneak that
baby in there
just sneaky just sneak it in there he's
a bet he's best god blessed us with
Steve Spurrier well and apparently Tim
Tebow revealed in his press conference
with the Mets they saw that that
Spurrier is constantly calling him to
play
listen Steve Steve Spurrier is a
indomitable force mhm and he is not to
be stopped and you know Tim called me
Tim called me after the press conference
is like hey I got a lot of questions
about you and Spurrier calling like man
we'd we'd love to have you if you're
gonna play baseball right you should I
mean look it's a completely different
skill set now he's spent a couple of
years doing it he and I have had I don't
know half a dozen conversations we spend
a bunch of time at the Super Bowl
I respect what he's doing and I'm
impressed by what he's doing and how
many people are even close to capable of
doing that but yeah if he wants to come
back and play sure well I mean look when
when the NF when the NFL Network
first broadcast a Thursday night
football game as you know the announcers
in the NFL Network the first ever
announcers in the NFL Network booth were
Bryant Gumbel and Chris Collinsworth and
I would proper to say this when the NFL
network was three weeks old which in a
way as despite the three years of
preparation Charlie that you've put in
your league is just three weeks now
coming up this weekend of showing the
product to the general sports using
Patterson there's no way just three
weeks three months into the NFL Network
that Brian Gumbel or Chris Collinsworth
would have said you know what I don't
mind being part of that I don't mind my
brand that I've built my entire career
being latched on to that hundred percent
so maybe a year in or something and
that's when Tebow if he's done with
baseball I know our goal is to be a
Developmental League for the NFL our
goal is to get players back to NFL it's
why we created the NFL out in our
contract it's why we only have NFL head
coaches it's why we create a system all
32 teams have sent scouts to all of our
games they have yeah so and they came to
our training camp we had a we had a
section in training camp it was just for
NFL to be able to do what they needed to
do so that they could see the players
and see the officials and see the
coaches we just sent Jon Kitna the
Cowboys so what we're looking for his
players who want to get back into the
NFL if Tim decided he wanted a shot at
playing in the NFL which is not his
ultimate dream he should play for us
because that's where he can do it any
player that wants to do it we're fully
supportive of that that's why we exist
if you want to play in a spring league
that is not about getting back to the
NFL do that but for us if you want the
ultimate dream and look our goal Bill
Polian and I and Tom Dunn 'don which is
a remarkable thing about tom is Tom
didn't just come in with money and
infrastructure he came in with a full
understanding what the vision was which
is to stand on the sidelines of the
Super Bowl next year and say I knew him
when he won the Alliance championship
and now he's playing in the Super Bowl
find me Kurt Warner's you know that
that's where our head goes and nobody's
ever attempted to do that before and I
think that's why we've been able to win
because the player quality is better so
Charlie ever saw the founder of the
Alliance of American football here
obviously you are well aware
the reports that came out prior to the
settling of the suit or grievance
between the league and colin kaepernick
that Kaepernick was reached out to by
the AAF is that by me you personally
read yeah Colin and I had a bunch of
conversations about it and I respect
Colin first of all I respect him as a
player I respect that he has a very
remarkable Drive and commitment to what
he believes in
I also believe he wants to play in the
NFL and so I called him and said look if
and when the time is ready and you
you're interested in this we would we
would love to be the path for you to be
able to do that but I respect if either
you can't or you don't want to and it
was great he he and I he met my wife we
had I mean we had very pleasant
conversations I'm but ultimately I
understand where his head and heart is
well was the reason why he didn't do it
is why can you reveal why he wouldn't
join the AAF did he I don't I think
that's his story to tell not mine okay
and and also I think one of the things
is ultimately I think Colin has shown
what the power of having your own voices
and I don't think as a league as an
owner as a founder it's my place to put
words in the mouth of players they
should have the about that was the goal
of our league we created a bonusing
system that bonuses players for being as
Hines Ward says the CEO of their own
brand we want to give that I think a lot
of the challenges that are the league's
have is that they the symptoms are what
we're seeing of the problems but at a
core we don't see players as ATM cards
for us we don't see them as commodities
we see them as partners and so we want
to encourage them to be able to do that
and I think hopefully that's a movement
we're able to tap into okay and and your
answer if that's his story to tell I
understand that but you also understand
my position so I'm gonna go follow up
please the number the dollar amount that
was thrown out there was that the reason
why that definitely best for me to let
Colin answer all those questions and
then let me ask you this the
conversation that people have that he
doesn't really want to play football
that he doesn't mean if that's true I'm
surprised because what I saw was a guy
who was in the gym three and a half
hours a day like
he's certainly I've known Colin for
quite some time I mean I did a show with
him a couple years ago for the Super
Bowl and he's a extraordinary athlete
well-built all everything you'd want in
that situation
he's certainly maintaining that so so
obviously health enthusiast Jerry wants
to play fly I'm just so understand
having this conversation I am NOT one of
I don't call myself an opinion aider or
you know obviously behind this Mike I
have to have opinions and let people
know what's going through my head
temples I'm not one to say that I don't
think he wants to play football anymore
that he wants to be a social activist
and use football as the platform I don't
think that I think he really wants to
play football I think he said he wants
to play in the NFL right and that by the
way we are not the enemy you're not the
NFL we're not trying to be the NFL we're
not trying to compete with the NFL we
are in essence a symbiotic partner a
Developmental League to improve the
ecosystem of football everything we've
done is to create a path for a trent
richardson to be able to reinvent
himself and say you know what all of
that stuff that happened in the past yes
was me playing for other people this is
me playing for myself and look what it's
happened look what Gary Gilbert Gary
Gilbert walked away from a futures
contract in the NFL to come play in our
league to do that so if a player wants
to that we support it but ultimately
let's not forget this guy five years ago
or four years ago was in the Super Bowl
right no and that's an and and I'm out
because everyone's like does you really
want to play football I think the guy
actually does want to play [ __ ] I think
we I think we're quite clear on the fact
that nobody has been able to pin this
guy down the way they wanted to they
want to label him as things he's this
he's that regardless of whether you
agree with him or not
right you cannot question the conviction
and you can't question what he was
willing to to put on the line and the
truth matters regardless of what he
decides to do
he certainly changed the game of
football and not doing it on the field
and I think you know we'll see what he
wants to do between the white lines but
he is a force of nature Charlie ever saw
the AF founder here on the show the
infusion of cash is that that one way to
put it for what Tom it's a heck of an
infusion 250 when it's a quarter
actually you know
quarter of a billion dollars the news
that this is needed obvious everyone
could use a quarter okay see anyone's
wondering I definitely need an what does
a quarter of a billion dollars right but
to make payroll was that not is that
true payroll yes do you think payroll is
a quarter of a billion dollars no just
that it next week should be real tough a
billion dollars a week we're probably
not running a great business now listen
here's the thing this is an investor who
is let's let's be very clear about who
Tom Denton is yes
Tom Dunnan started from nothing and at
twenty started a business that made
billions of dollars right he is a very
very smart businessman and he unknown
unbeknownst to me was looking at my
business for over a year
yeah and had close friends and ties
people that you and I are very close to
in the media business I got a call from
somebody who I respect who runs a
fortune 50 company on Wednesday morning
and he said there's someone I think you
really need to have a conversation with
who's interested in coming in and that
was seven at 7:30 in the morning I got
on the phone tom done then he said this
is how I would do this here's how the
money there's what I think you do with
money but here's the infrastructure that
I can give you and it was a I mean the
the truly unfortunate nature of being a
startup is you make mistakes most most
startups don't have the challenge of
being on the national stage the way we
are so we switch payroll companies and
it's you know it's gotten blown into
something that's really unfortunate and
and I and I've spent a lot of time
talking to a lot of players apologizing
for what we did we thought we were
making it better by putting them on a
system that would have the insurance the
way it did and everything we probably
should have done it two weeks earlier
we've learned our lesson there but that
was a confluence of events with what
happened Tom Tom he completely changes
everything I go from being a startup
company this is what he said to me on
the phone this is the first conversation
he said listen you've raised your series
a and you're gonna raise your series B
and then you're gonna go raise your
series C or you could take my money and
we'll just call it your series infinity
and I was like what does that even mean
he said you will never want for money
again
like what now do I sign
what does it actually mean look not only
am I going to give you money I'm gonna
give you infrastructure this is a guy we
who he took me into a meeting with the
heads of AT&T a couple of days ago yeah
and as we're walking I could have done
that for your child or not the court of
ability this is the part you can't do
we're walking out of the building and I
say man this meeting came together in
like six hours how did it happen and one
of the top three people at 18 t goes it
helps that Tom owns the building yeah
that's right I can't do that yeah I was
like dropping the mic like I have to
keep picking up so Tom can say something
else and I can drop it again well I mean
look Charlie obviously you need to have
four to be successful year to have buzz
you gotta have people talking about you
and you gotta have people trying to poke
holes and trying to tear you down you
know that better than anybody else so
I'll say you need colin kaepernick no
well you wouldn't come cuz you wouldn't
pay him well you need to this money cuz
you wouldn't make payroll and you know
that people are saying that potentially
to try and make sure you're not
succeeding i calling tom during that
whole thing and saying like look i I
don't what do we say and he was like
nothing like they're talking about us
they're talking about us endlessly yeah
Tom's got a little Jerry in him easy let
me let me be really clear i we
internally called tom NSA not screwing
around
yeah he's the guy who comes in and is
just like this is how we're doing it and
and and has the has the vision of how to
actually execute it and then the chops
behind it I've never been in a situation
like that before this was a startup keep
mine everyone who tried to do this
before I had infrastructure they had the
WWE they had NBC and General Electric
they had all this stuff burn Tom comes
in and in an instant takes me from a
let's call it an adolescent company
that's getting through it
hmm doing a fully structured adult
company in in minutes so we're gonna go
to the combine next week and we're gonna
sit down with people and we're not
having conversations about you know tell
me about what the backdrop is I'm just
saying here's the new chairman of my
board and oh by the way google him and
you know charlie Eversole here on the
show some of the things that you have
done with the broadcast because you did
have CBS NFL Network and you mentioned
Turner I love listening in on the replay
I know I told Pereira and Blin love
love it I told them you guys realize you
just wrote yourself a job well you know
what though they can still we can still
listen in and this is one of the reasons
why I don't know if the NFL would do it
if you we're listening them
misinterpreted live you know and so in
any of the conversations you've had with
the NFL have you heard maybe an appetite
of them saying we like that we so we
have a lot of conversation obviously
they're not only our network partner but
they're our partner in a bunch of
different areas and Abhi's and and we
worked closely with them and the PA to
create a situation where our players can
leave under contract to go play in the
NFL right all of our rules committee
well everyone that's on our Rules
Committee was on at some point time or
currently is on the NFL's rules
committees a competition committee same
thing so we did not other than the sky
judge which was was was Polian and
pereira thinking of hey let's put a
ninth official in the box and what
pereira mentions the sky judge is the
answer to the NFL's idea he keeps
mention I try I trademarked it doe
because there's definitely a
three-picture deal tell me Keanu Reeves
is not the sky judge tell me that right
now merchants out of the back room tell
them to come in here we got his next
things are all things that came out of
deep conversations with them I'm not a
fan of the sky judge cuz I've in all
honesty cuz I want to see a flag thrown
on a field I want to know that there's
been a penalty that I don't want to know
place done wait a minute somebody who
can't throw a flag has technically here
on it and that drives me nuts as I'm
already driven nuts as a fan when
there's a flag on the opposite side of
the field on a related here's my let me
let me let me take one shot at
convincing you okay the NFC Championship
had stopped you could stop they had 64
cameras they had 64 cameras on the game
yep you want two guys running backwards
well to whatever 21 year old guys are up
in the air doing all says have blind to
the to the official where he is you just
want us to rely on someone running back
we're not doing subjective calls we're
not doing crazy stuff but agreed
stuff that completely alters the outcome
of the game right then don't get me
wrong it's good for all of you guys
because it gives you four news cycles to
talk about how they blew the call
ultimately you're talking about you how
much franchises that are worth billions
and billions of dollars that are being
decided by somebody running backwards
with trying to catch what they saw no
man you you want a level of fairness I
don't want to replay every call our
games are two and a half hours they're
fast and they're fun okay let me respond
to that first of all all you ever come
on this show and call me a you guy okay
that's not accepting them no no no you
guys stop stop stop
Charlie get back in your seat no what I
am saying is even as somebody who does
appreciate the value of endless news
cycles yes I would prefer to remove that
I don't need the news cycles I'd rather
that call be gotten right and if you do
replay everything if you replay
everything it will not extend the game
they spend they spent four minutes and
something like 45 seconds replaying
whether or not Edelman grazed the ball
right on the field and what that was
your guess is as good as mine if they
got it right I think they did get it
right yeah I know but you're looking at
2k camera and if we had a 4k camera I
don't know it looks like there was a
fabric of his globe all then for the
sake of time let's stipulate on this
that we might not agree on the sky judge
do you think the NFL has an appetite to
let us in on listening to the art
McNally replay Center in New York talk
to an official I think that you're doing
well here's the thing I'll tell you
there are and we've had deep
conversations about this there are
technical challenges that are unique to
that problem right that don't exist for
us because we could just put we have our
replay judge in the stadium got there so
there is a technical challenge that
would need to be resolved I think
transparent look I'm I believe in
transparency
I I also think that at the end of the
day in the age of information
having someone pontificate on what they
think is going on versus showing what's
going on makes no sense right so I think
that there's value I think you're gonna
see a lot of pressure from the networks
to say this is look how effective this
was I think it's great I think the other
thing is miking the coaches I don't know
some coaches might not
Oakley's are gonna kick and scream you
all you need is one Hall of Fame head
coach having something that is overheard
cuz no disrespect to the AF Smike
they'll to foe over there as the wrong
button by something like that you know
what year was Singletary inducted in the
Hall of Fame no chance any he was on a
mic and there's no chance that he even
knows which team Mike Singletary coaches
in the AF none he absolutely knows it's
a Memphis Express I am hear from you
there we go
got one more here but uh cuz I need to
know how the hell Mike tell to foe got
hired the best yeah the AFS Charlie ever
saw a little bit more with my good buddy
when we come back this day in history
The Miracle on Ice happened on this day
back in nineteen
eleven chicken you getting sick
[Applause]
well you just get boost function you're
an owl and Ken Dryden Charlie Eversole
here at the AAF was your dad that game
was your dad involved the Olympics at
that time in 1980 1980
geez well you were born two years later
yeah I do remember that I remember that
is there anybody better than now no
there's I mean honestly he called me he
called me just before kick-off and he
and Madden have been two of my sort of
spanglish Charlie boy you got a Charlie
boy call from him Charlie boy
what'd he say to you he said he said you
know no matter what happens
congratulations about LA and then I
walked out of the game and I'm walking
to the press conference my phone rings
and I instinctively answer it and it's
al he goes do you believe put everything
else aside hey when I did the London
game this year and al sent me akuto on
email no and I thought her - right away
- Suzy who you know my wife and she's
just like we gotta frame that I had to
say this every time I come on the show
but I just want to drive home the fact
when I first moved to LA I was alone I
had nobody you and Suzy took me in for
Thanksgiving dinner good man
the guys are good people I've been to
fewer you're a good man you're you have
a great great wife that's true that's a
fact nobody understands how great she is
and what trickery is being mysterious
that's the beard I think is the yes and
she was the big proponent of the beard I
can like that's why that's why it's had
so much think I like it we know by the
way you know we're taking part I do know
that the Memphis franchise is obviously
the the official the official charity of
the Memphis Express is finitude today
and I think some of the members of the
Memphis Express are gonna run for T's
next week some of the members of all of
our teams are attaboy
are you gonna run a 40 I'll be at the
combine no no
yeah I am I'm gonna be really family
look like you're gonna get down there
and you're gonna you're gonna fire out
you're gonna try to San Diego this
weekend can I do in a suit please yes
it's your workplace it's your workplace
in your work clothes and you're not it
and if anybody says he's ripping me off
show them a photograph of me and the
bomber jacket that you put me in back in
the day greater smoke by the greatest
moment of the whole show it's like 4:00
a.m. red we're at Alcatraz the head of
the network is standing in 18 inches of
water rewriting the teleprompter while
rich is standing on a rock doing this
[ __ ] and I are looking at each other
like what is going what is hot right now
with our lives
hey Charlie congratulations one one
other thing I'd love to see the NFL
adopt the the onside kick in quotes that
you do has anybody done a fort a fourth
and 10 from their own 34 didn't in
pre-season I don't know we've done this
season yeah I love it it's so good
fourth and 12 its fourth and 12 12 it's
a it's a mathematical equation 15 is the
exact same likelihood you have of
getting of converting a onside kick okay
fourth and 12 fourth and 10 the
percentage is too high right yeah fourth
and 12 is is sort of it's our Goldilocks
what is it what is it what's the
percentage like the conversion yeah our
conversion er or the NFL conversion
Amundson 12
well we haven't run any of pre-season so
I mean in training camp it was we were
like 30-something percent I love it you
want to see the hands team makes no
sense I love it Charlie Congrats on
everything going on thanks for the pin
I've been wearing my AF pin this entire
tune in this weekend
primetime Saturday and Sunday for those
of you who are just not gonna watch the
Oscars we wanted to give you something
for you and tune in to San Antonio at
San Diego to hear how great it sounds of
course for Mike del 2 phone thanks for
giving him another gig back Sunday night
baby
Charlie Eversole here on the show so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience